de toutes les mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement
c'est elle qui fait le plus parler
réduire la vitesse de 90 à 80 km/heure
permettra-t-il de baisser le nombre de
morts sur les routes au niveau de la
nationale 10 près de trappes les
conducteurs sont divisés sur la question
c'est pas normal
parce que on ne vivrait à vendre après
avoir été un peu plus vite on va devoir
et après pour les accidents c'est pas
mal mais bon
sinon c'est vrai que bientôt on va
rouler à 60 sur l'autoroute moi je
trouve ça trop lent déjà 90 c'est dur
alors 80 ça va être encore plus dur que
laura moye d'accès dans la digue km ça
m'étonnerait pour le gouvernement cette
mesure qui sera appliquée sur près de
400 mille kilomètres de réseau routier
permettra de sauver jusqu'à 400 vies par
an des chiffres réfutés par certaines
associations d'automobilistes pour l
exécutif se trompe de cible et
chercherait avant tout à faire un coup
politique
vous êtes contrôlés tous les jours
pratiquement idée d'un leurre est ce que
vous a été contrôlé récemment avec votre
taux d'alcoolémie c'est extrêmement rare
voyez donc il n'y a pas que ça il ya
aussi la distraction au volant il ya la
somnolence les routes c'est que dans 47
% des accidents il ya un facteur routier
qui est impliqué en 2012 basse qualité
de la route 2012 où tu es champion du
monde pour notre réseau routier en 2016
on est à la septième place on s'est
complètement dégradée dans le
département des yvelines plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres pourrait être
soumis à cet abaissement à partir du 1er
juillet le plan du gouvernement prévoit
également un renforcement important des
sanctions pour l'utilisation des
téléphones portables au volant